given that which we just heard from
professor witty given the infection
rates given the hospitalization rates
are you still
comfortable with the great unlocking
that is coming on monday
well you're right that infection rates
are still rising but
the situation we're in at the moment is
that around 80 percent of people have
had their first vaccine
and over two-thirds have had their
second vaccine
and we know that we have weakened the
link between the infection rates the
hospitalizations and deaths and so
now is a good time to loosen those those
restrictions because
if we don't do it now when are we going
to do it
well perhaps in a few weeks time when
more people have been vaccinated
well we did wait you will remember we
did we were meant to be opening up on
june the 21st but
uh the government made the decision to
delay that to enable more people to be
vaccinated
and we are we've beaten uh the target
that we set
for those second vaccinations by a week
uh and so now we are moving
uh from legal restrictions to people
taking
personal responsibility uh so when we
are saying to people
do continue to be cautious do take
measures
uh but now we are just taking away those
legal restrictions
because of the success of the vaccine
program but
let's just dwell just for a second on
that which we heard from you know none
other than the
chief medical officer chris whitty said
this i don't think we should
underestimate the fact that we could get
into trouble again surprisingly fast
things could look a lot worse in five
six seven eight weeks time that's the
chief medical officer
saying in essence that in a little over
a month we could see restrictions coming
back in isn't it
well he did say and that matters could
escalate and of course
that is true but he also said let's look
at
how where we have uh come from and let's
look at
also that we're not in the same place
that we were
when restrictions first went in we have
the vaccination program
we have the genomic sequencing to detect
new strains we have the test and trace
system we are fully
stocked with pp and all those other
things that we just didn't have
when restrictions came came in place and
the key to all this
uh has been the vaccination program
because we know that you're
much less likely to get a severe
illness uh if you are double vaccinated
sure but
i'll repeat the question chris witty
saying you know in five six seven eight
weeks time we
we may need to look at things again that
is the chief medical officer saying
that in england with in a little over a
month we could see a return to
restrictions isn't it
well i think the health secretary has
been very clear as has the prime
minister that we will
see infections rise um but the reason
why the restrictions are being taken
away
is because of the vaccination program
which will protect people when those
infection rates do rise and of course if
we get into a
situation where uh it's unacceptable um
and uh we do need to put back further
restrictions then
that of course is something the
government uh will look at
but you know we're going into the summer
a large number of people have been
vaccinated
and we've had a really tough time we're
still asking people to take
responsibility
and we do need to ask ourselves if we
don't open up now when will we
will we be able to open up yep as you
say mr fraser we are asking people to to
to do you exercise their own judgment
we're asking people to to go slowly but
we've got 140 000 people pitching up at
silverstone this weekend
well there are some large events and of
course there are measures
in relation to those large events but
what i've seen over the
course of the last year is people taking
a huge amount of personal responsibility
and not always um just abiding by the
rules but going
beyond the rules i've seen people you
know outsider wearing masks
where they don't have to and and there
are
different restrictions uh in different
places for different reasons and
of course the measures uh will be
changing um on next monday
i i just wonder if we can dwell just for
a moment on on the the the covered up
the
the nhs app pinged 520 194 people
in the week leading up to to july the
7th that's not sustainable is it we're
already beginning to see businesses
complaining about the fact that
production lines are in essence
literally grinding to a halt
well i understand people's frustration
in relation to that but we must remember
it is an important tool the
self-isolation tool
and but we have already announced of
course that on august the 16th
again the measures will change and if
you are fully vaccinated
you won't have to isolate uh but instead
take a test
sure but that is a that is a month away
and we're not yet even at as
as ministers have stopped calling it we
used to freedom day we're four days away
from monday the only thing that is going
to happen when we relax restrictions is
that more people will be getting pinged
500 000 in the week to july the 7th one
wonders what it's going to be in a
couple of weeks time perhaps
reaching into the millions
well as i said it is an important tool
because it is important that you do
isolate if you've
come into contact i know this is
something the government is looking at
in addition to the changes uh in
mid-august the government is always also
carrying out a number of pilots
to see whether instead of isolating once
you get pinged
you could uh take a test so the
government is looking at this uh
very very carefully recognizing the
significant impact
uh that is having on businesses um
medical experts in the british medical
journal have been have been pretty
scathing about the plans for the july
the 19th they've claimed that the
government's strategy of
as they describe infection over
vaccination unethical and unscientific
i just wonder if you have a response to
the bmj describing the government
strategy as
again unethical and unscientific
well the the government acts uh basing
its decisions its political decisions
based on scientific evidence uh and what
it's seen
uh in this period uh coming up to july
the 19th is that although infection
rates
are rising the link between infections
hospitalizations and death is weakening
so if i if i give you
um some recent statistics um we
recently i i believe this is yesterday
uh but the numbers might be
slightly off that we had around 40 000
infections we had around 500
hospitalizations
and around 50 deaths so there is of
course all those hospitalizations
are of concern and even more so the
deaths but there is a significant
difference
between the number of infections uh and
the translation
into hospitalizations and deaths
well actually i mean you are correct i
mean the figures have changed slightly
from that rather than
40 000 it was almost 50 000 new cases
yesterday the high since january the
15th
rather than 500 hospital admissions as
you said it was 621.
we've got 3241 beds occupied compared
with 2209
last wednesday things are getting bad
very very quickly
as chris whittie said
i don't think that the health secretary
has
suggested anything otherwise then the
infection rate is going to rise
and as a consequence of the infection
rate rising
that means um because there is a link
between the two
that it follows that hospitalizations
and deaths
will rise as well but there are also
consequences
to not opening up real consequences not
just
to people's jobs and the economy but to
mental health as well
also to people who haven't been going to
the doctor
because they fear it there is a we
and so it is really important that we
get the balance right
between ensuring that we keep this virus
under control
and we take the necessary clinical
measures to do that
but that we also recognize there are
consequences
of not opening up and not allowing
people uh to go about
their their daily lives mr we do
appreciate you taking so much time to
speak on stuff that is technically away
from your brief i just wonder if we can
move it slightly closer to it um
the statute of limitations that is being
uh introduced
uh to deal with uh prosecutions relating
to actions during the troubles in
northern ireland
all five political parties in northern
ireland are opposed to this the irish
government as opposed to this
provisionals on both sides are opposed
to this is it time for a rethink
so the the issue in relation to this is
that as time moves on
the chances of getting uh prosecution
successful convictions
um gets lower and i know that this issue
is causing um a lot of um
a lot of issues uh in in in ireland
and and it is important that we get
engage on this subject
uh and the rifts are developing and i
know that the government
is engaging with all parties i will
continue to do so
uh before it brings forward any
legislation